[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de la Frixo et
les bienvenus sur France 24 à la une ce
soir Mahamad débit investi président au
Tchad le chef de la jungle au pouvoir et
maintenu encore deux ans à la tête du
pays après la prolongation de la
transition une prolongation suite au
dialogue national des billes pourra se
présenter à l'issue de cette transition
à la présidentielle en République
démocratique du Congo quelle Eve moutun
homme fort du régime Kabila et de retour
à Kinshasa il avait quitté le pays en
mars 2021 pour fuir des poursuites
judiciaires il est accusé entre autres
d'arrestation arbitraire et de torture
ce retour pose question dans le pays et
nous serons à Kinshasa dans ce journal
nous parlerons également de l'Algérie
avec la visite de la première ministre
Elisabeth borne mais aussi à travers un
documentaire qui revient sur la
complexité des relations entre les deux
pays la réalisatrice Viviane Candas et
notre invité ce soir
investi ce lundi au Tchad après 18 mois
au pouvoir il est maintenu à la tête
d'une transition prolongée de deux ans
une décision prise à l'issue du dialogue
national le général de 38 ans pourra
également se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle il avait pourtant promis
de se tenir à l'écart de ce scrutin
Camille et délai
le général devenu président pour la
deuxième fois
président de transition
l'investiture et le début d'une deuxième
phase de transition de 24 mois les
autorités disent vouloir mener des
élections à la fin de cette période et
rendre le pouvoir à un gouvernement
civil c'est l'heure du dialogue de
réconciliation nationale qu'il a été
décidée pourrait se présenter avec des
pouvoirs élargis le président peut
choisir directement son premier ministre
et son gouvernement ce qui l'a promis de
faire prochainement
sera pleinement consacré à la mise en
oeuvre de conclusion du dialogue
national inclusif et souverain et à la
mise en place d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale
depuis le décès de son père Idriss Déby
Itno en avril 2021
Idriss Déby était l'homme fort du pays
pendant plus de 30 ans la jante
militaire avait alors déclenché une
première période de transition il y a 18
moi à l'époque Mama débit a promis de
prendre exemple sur son père et voilà
c'est cher un autre défunt président
seront éprouvés et sanctualisés dans le
cadre d'un dialogue national inclusif
qui sera organisé pendant cette période
de transition
l'investiture a été boycoté par la
majorité de l'opposition politique des
représentants de l'Union africaine ont
aussi été absents après avoir exigé la
fin de la période de transition des
représentants de la France et l'Union
européenne quant à eux étaient présents
le procès du massacre du stade de
Conakry le 28 septembre 2009 se poursuit
en Guinée la demande de mise en
résidence surveillée de l'ancien chef de
la junte Moussa Dadis Camara a été
rejeté par la justice la roquette avait
été formulée par ses avocats écouter les
réactions des différentes parties au
micro de notre correspondant à Conakry
Malik Diakité
cette décision vraiment elle n'est pas
conforme à la loi nous avons demandé la
résidence sur ce sont des questions qui
auraient pu être accueillis
favorablement mais nous avons compris
que le tribunal est rentré en rejet
systématique de toutes nos demandes déjà
nous devons être sur nos gardes
parce que la décision qui est intervenue
déjà nous donne à réfléchir et nous
sommes entièrement satisfaits de cette
décision puisque il faut il faut
rétablir l'équilibre entre les accusés
donc nous pensons que ça a mis en
détention se justifie par l'article 252
et que de ce point de vue il doit venir
au tribunal en tant que prisonnier pour
que il soit jugé conformé à la loi et en
présence de tous les autres co accusés
quel est le moutun de retour en
République démocratique du Congo
l'ancien patron de l'agence nationale
des renseignements avait quitté le pays
en mars 2021 pour fuir des poursuites
judiciaires il est accusé entre autres
d'arrestation arbitraire et de torture
que le moutun fait l'objet de sanctions
européennes et américaines pour avoir
planifié dirigé au commis de graves
violations des droits humains à Kinshasa
le retour de l'ancien homme fort du
régime Kabila pose question la
correspondance d'Aurélie bazarra
kibangula
difficile de savoir la date exacte du
retour de kalef mouton à Kinshasa une
source proche de la présidence affirme
que l'ancien patron de l'agence
nationale des renseignements a été
auditionné deux fois la semaine dernière
par la justice ici dans la capitale
congolaise après un an de fuite cette
Aix hommes fort du régime Kabila serait
revenu pour négocier l'abandon de ces
poursuites judiciaires auprès des
autorités alors certains opposants qui
avaient été arrêtés sous la direction de
calèves mouton disent qu'il faut
définitivement classer ce dossier c'est
le cas de Jean-Bertrand et Wanga s'est
exposant s'est entretenu par téléphone
avec Kalev mouton il dit avoir pardonné
son ancien bourreau et affirme qu'il
faut maintenant aller de l'avant un
discours qui a fait réagir des membres
de la société civile comme carbone Benny
membre du mouvement Philippe il accuse
Kalev mouton d'avoir fait arrêter puis
torturé beaucoup de militants des droits
de l'homme et des opposants il demande
que justice soit rendue et que ce
dossier servait d'exemples dit-il pour
éviter que l'Agence Nationale des
renseignements ne redevienne un
instrument de répression
la visite d'Elizabeth borne en Algérie
la première ministre a été reçue
aujourd'hui par le président algérien
Abdelmadjid Boni il était question de
donner une dynamique à la visite
d'Emmanuel Macron à Alger fin août
Elizabeth borne était accompagnés de 15
ministres et 70 chefs d'entreprise la
coopération économique était au centre
de ce voyage mais pas seulement Kevin
Baptista
dernier honneur pour Elisabeth borne en
Algérie
la première ministre est reçu par le
président algérien Abdelmadjid
teboundorgue d'une visite censée
concrétiser le rapprochement initié par
Paris et Alger l'été dernier regardons
vers l'avenir nous voulons que la
déclaration d'Alger s'incarne dans des
actes et dans un engagement durable et
bénéfique pour nos deux pays et pour nos
deux peuples pour y parvenir Paris à
dépêcher pas moins d'une quinzaine de
ministres à Alger en plus des gestes
symboliques une douzaine d'accord
bilatéraux ont été signés domaine visé
les coopérations économiques culturelles
éducatives un moyen de répondre au
dossier délicat des visas
nous avons convenu de concrétiser
l'ouverture incluse dans la déclaration
d'Alger sur cette question de travailler
ensemble afin de généraliser de
faciliter réellement la circulation des
personnes
depuis un an Paris a réduit le nombre de
visa accordé aux Algériens une mesure de
rétorsion pour forcer à Alger à
davantage accorder de laisser passer
consulaire pour ses ressortissants
soumis à une obligation de quitter le
territoire français reste l'autre grand
sujet de tension entre les deux
capitales la mémoire de la guerre
d'Algérie il avance selon Elisabeth
borne la composition d'une commission
d'historien des deux pays devrait être
bouclé dans les prochains jours le
Premier ministre algérien s'y est aussi
engagé sans annoncer d'avancer concrète
les deux chefs de gouvernement se sont
dit confiants sur la question mémorielle
et on reste en Algérie pour parler ce
soir des possibles passerelles entre les
deux pays nous recevons Viviane Candas
réalisatrice elle est venue nous
présenter le documentaire Marseille au
pluriel un documentaire que revient sur
les liens de part et d'autre de la
Méditerranée la complexité des relations
entre la France et l'Algérie la
difficulté rencontrée par l'immigration
algérienne en France notamment face à la
montée de l'extrême droite merci
beaucoup viennent Candas d'être avec
nous ce soir merci de m'avoir invité
vraiment alors j'aimerais que vous me
disiez pourquoi vous aviez décidé de
travailler sur ce sujet
mes liens personnels avec l'histoire
algérienne puisque j'ai des parents qui
se sont impliqués dans la dépendance la
guerre d'Algérie et l'indépendance de
l'Algérie en tant qu'avocat du FLN que
j'ai vécu en Algérie enfants et je suis
toujours resté j'ai revu d'ailleurs
actuellement pour préparer un film et
j'ai toujours été très sensible à ce
sujet dans mes années marseillaises de
jeunesse j'ai donc eu
des liens avec des personnes qui étaient
issues de l'immigration algérienne et
eux-mêmes de la guerre d'Algérie et en
1986 évidemment quand j'ai commencé à
faire des des films quand j'ai commencé
à tourner mais venu pas l'idée mais
c'était vraiment ça me semblait une
urgence que de faire un travail sur ce
qui se passait à Marseille qui était
vraiment une ville où à la fois il y
avait une forte immigration algérienne
de toute façon il y a une forte
immigration puisque un tiers de la
population aujourd'hui vient de de
toutes sortes d'immigration comme Oriane
etc mais algérienne particulièrement vu
l'histoire il y avait et le Front
national à ce moment-là commencer à
faire une percée importante électorale
importante donc j'ai fait un premier
tournage en 1986
que j'ai complété bien plus tard plus de
35 ans plus tard dans 2018 et nous
l'avons terminé le film en 2021 voilà
on voit des justement des vieilles
interviews qui sont aussi commentées par
rapport à la situation aujourd'hui donc
ce film a été réalisé en grande partie
en France mais il n'a pas trouvé de
distributeur en revanche il serait
diffusé en Algérie il y aura plein
d'événements aussi il va y avoir il y a
des événements en France là à Vitrolles
le 22 octobre je vais présenter un
ancien film Algérie du possible et
Marseille c'est à 21h donc c'est
intéressant Vitrolles parce que c'était
une ville qui a été
Front national depuis 20 ans le Parti
socialiste a repris le pouvoir mais
c'est quand même une ville très marquée
par par l'extrême droite donc c'est
intéressant d'aller faire cette
présentation là bas et nous aurons une
diffusion et ça c'est une première
en général les
les documentaires français ne sont pas
diffusés sur les chaînes algériennes
mais ce documentaire est une sorte de
miroir finalement qui est tordu à la
France sur son rapport avec ce autour
d'une famille immigrée de Marseille puis
une famille algérienne donc c'est un
film qui peut tout à fait qui intéresse
la chaîne mémoire qui est la chaîne
Histoire de l'an TV de la télévision
algérienne et il va être diffusé à
l'occasion alors maintenant il a été
question du 17 octobre et ça va
probablement être pour l'anniversaire de
l'attentat du 14 décembre
1973 à Marseille qui avait coûté la vie
à plusieurs personnes et qui était une
bombe posée au consulat d'Algérie par un
groupe Charles Martel les responsables
n'ayant jamais été retrouvés dans le
commentaire alors on a vu Elisabeth
borne qui se rend à Alger la première
ministre parmi les sujets il y a
l'économie mais en parler aussi de
passerelles il y a aussi le la culture
et le cinéma Emmanuel Macron s'était
rendu Alger aussi avec des réalisateurs
notamment Yamina Benguigui
qu'attendez-vous vous en tant que
réalisatrice de cette visite qu'est-ce
que vous souhaitez voir naître entre les
deux pays et bien une collaboration plus
plus précise on est dans un moment où la
France le cinéma français est en crise
avec une baisse d'exploitation des des
salles de cinéma les gens ne vont plus
dans les salles en particulier la
jeunesse n'y va pas
il y a en Algérie beaucoup de
possibilités il y a des décors
magnifiques et des comédiens et des
comédiennes formidables il y a des
techniciens et des techniciennes qui
sont excellents il y a tout à fait les
moyens de tourner en Algérie des choses
et j'espère que ça va se développer moi
je suis sur le point de tourner un long
métrage qui n'est pas un documentaire
c'est l'adaptation d'un compte des mille
et une nuits et c'est une histoire qui a
beaucoup traîné qui a été ralentie par
le covid et d'autres problèmes et qui va
se débloquer maintenant moi je crois
beaucoup beaucoup au potentiel algériens
du point de vue du cinéma merci beaucoup
Viviane kandas merci d'être venu sur
notre plateau et on suivra vos
prochaines réalisations ici dans le
journal de l'Afrique merci infiniment
c'est la fin du journal de l'Afrique
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
la suite de Paris direct
[Musique]